[Music]
it is a central question in the Roman
Catholic Church should priests maintain
the centuries-old stance on celibacy now
to Pope's past and present could find
themselves on different sides of the
debate
Pope Benedict the 16th who pledged to
remain hidden from the world when he
retired in 2013 has broken his silence
to passionately defend celibacy in a new
book benedict who became the first pope
in more than 600 years to resign because
of ill health said the tradition allows
priests to focus on their duties the
comments come at a time when Pope
Francis is considering easing a ban on
married men serving as priests South
American bishops have called for a
change to help end a shortage of priests
particularly in indigenous communities
in the Amazon Pope Francis the first
Latin American Pope is said to have an
instinctive understanding of the
region's challenges it is pope francis
who will make any final decision with a
surprise intervention from pope benedict
underscores fundamental divisions in the
1.3 billion member church many Catholics
who ever deny Francis and Benedict have
different views on married priests what
benedict beliefs about priestly celibacy
is exactly the same as what Pope Francis
believes the Synod on the Amazon asked
him look at there are communities who
don't get a priest even once a year
could we consider ordaining some deacons
who are there who are married with
families and this is something the Pope
is considering and as an exception and
I'm sure that if he says yes
Benedict will be happy with it and if he
says no the same some married Anglican
priests who converted to Catholicism are
allowed to carry on in their ministries
but some traditionalists within the
Roman Catholic Church fear that Pope
Francis is leading them in a direction
they don't want to follow since becoming
Pope Francis has emerged as a reformer
tackling sexual abuse and corruption
within the church he also seems willing
to consider loosening a grip on
conservative values so important
his predecessors NIMH Barca al-jazeera
London